on this episode I'm going to find out if
you have the goods the chops the it
redhead quarterbacks and finally me
forgetting something
what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is askgaryvee
episode 6 Jason asks what's the best way
to use Facebook dark posts Jason what's
up man this is a great question to start
episode sex with because it's a general
question that I want everybody to pay
attention to Jason is asking about face
book dark pose you might be figuring out
how to make Instagram work or the
up-and-coming amazing Pinterest CPC ad
platform or anything native ads on out
brain and tubulin hexagram the real
answer to this Jason is to become a
practitioner the right price for your
ads is always a moving variable based on
supply and demand competition all that
jazz the way to become good at it is to
do it you can go step one go to youtube
and Google and look up all the
information and figure out how to become
better at Facebook dark posts read 30
articles on all facebook.com/ about how
to be better at Facebook dark posts you
can do all the homework but until you
apply it it's just knowledge isn't it
and I love students but only so much and
so the answer to your question my friend
is very simple become educated and
execute that's how everything works for
every single answer on all these issues
to find out the right price there is no
right price Jason the right price is the
right price right this second because
the supply and demand curve of what
you're trying to apply if you're trying
to sell furniture and you're one of two
people buying ads on Facebook dark posts
for furnitures your cost is gonna be a
better deal than in three weeks when
five people are there trying to bid that
up supply and demand supply and demand
don't ask do you feel it's still a
necessary call to action to push
subscribers from social channels to a
website or newsletter signup dawn who
says I ever thought it was a necessary
call to action cuz the answer is I
didn't and I don't know I don't know I
didn't what I mean by that is sure I
think it's a good idea to push to a
website right now especially if you're
selling something on that website but in
a world where you can buy that same
product right on Twitter right on
Facebook do you necessarily need to
schlep somebody to your site to make
them buy that when when it's native
right for them and they can just buy it
in there no the answer is no isn't it
because friction sucks
right
friction sucks and consumers do not want
friction so anything that allows you to
execute within the police you're in
that's what you're gonna like and so my
answer to your question is less and less
every day people who say Gary why aren't
you driving people to garyvaynerchuk.com
why are you putting out content on
YouTube why are you putting out content
of medium why are you putting content on
LinkedIn because I want awareness I'm
putting out content for awareness and to
build relationships with all of you
that's what I'm doing and thus what that
is doing is creating a scenario where
those channels allow me to do that just
because I'm not driving them to my duck
you know many people give you bad
marketing advice that say you have to
drive to your website for what to
collect the email last time I checked a
tweet card that collects email has been
the most efficient way that I've
collected email better than driving to
my com4 what what are you selling
advertising on your site if you're
selling advertising on your site then
maybe that's the thing you can do but
you can also sell advertising to people
within your social channels and run that
arbitrage so the fact of the matter is
done is that I think people are just not
really that educated on what they're
trying to achieve and so I've never been
worried about forcing somebody to a.com
unless that was the right strategy at
the right time to drive the result the
fact that even ecommerce buying within a
tweet and a Facebook post has now gotten
native to the platform has eliminated a
lot of the reasons that you have to
drive somebody nam asks how did you deal
with working in a family business nam
very carefully family businesses are
difficult I'm in my second one my dad my
brother I look forward to my one with my
kids one day Misha and Xander if you
want to be an entrepreneur call me um
you know I I think the real answer is
Nam the reason I've had two successful
family businesses is very simply and
kudos to my dad and kudos to my mom and
kudos to just a lot of fortune things
that allowed my dad and I and now my
brother and I to allow our love to trump
our our pride our competitiveness our
business POVs somehow in our specific
situation probably predicated with a lot
of hard work
specifically for my mom more than you
would think and my dad and then the
incredible natural DNA that they gifted
me we have created a situation where
we've allowed at the end of the day for
us not to lose focus on the fact that we
love each other more than we care about
getting our way
Nate asks what did you think of the
Dalton deal
Nate ironically I'm one of these kind of
people that actually believe very
heavily in Andy Dalton and even though
he crapped the bed in the playoffs I
actually thought it was a good deal I
thought they should lock him up
quarterbacks are tough to come by
especially red-headed quarterbacks
that's a big shadow to the redheads not
the other way around and finally I just
thought it was a solid signing that many
of you in the comments section will
disagree and say he sucks and this and
that and the bottom line is we'll see
see in 10 years I will come back to this
episode go into the comments and I'll
even give you your props or I'll say
told you Tyron asks does the demand for
your attention get overwhelming tea very
honestly the demand for my attention is
something that I'm so flabbergasted and
humbled and grateful for I'm sure it's
overwhelming shorts probably
overwhelming right now but I'm unable to
quantify that against the enormous pride
I have in and thankfulness and just glee
over all that people actually want to
watch a show where I give my two cents I
mean and I'm given three cents here
[ __ ] and so you know I the
answer is uh it doesn't feel super
overwhelming dreck it asks if you had to
do it all over again today would you
start with Wine Library TV or Wine
Library first
directing great question men I've got to
say something look a couple things
actually before I answer to find
question and sign off on this show a
dragon that's a great question but the
two things one you guys are killing it
with questions I'm hitting the hash tag
and seeing these all come through I'm
completely blown away I mean I was a
little worried that they'd all be the
redundant same questions you guys are
coming from all sorts of angles so I
appreciate - you know this may be a
scenario where some people's questions
who watch this show every single day are
not going to get answered for the first
six months because of the lottery
randomness and so I apologize up front
keep asking them thank you so much I'm
humbled and to answer your question
hands down I would do it over again
exactly the way I did it having the
comfort that I'd built this enormous
business before I started the show put
myself out there in this zany way and
had that ear cover of respect for what I
accomplished and what I knew helped me
so much if I started the show when I
came out the gate when maybe I didn't
know as much about wine I didn't know as
much about the wine business I didn't
know as much about the audience it
wouldn't have been as good you know
chops skills the goods they have a funny
way of working themselves out and so no
matter how you roll if you can bring it
it's a hell of a lot more consumable I
appreciate the questions at six the fun
fact for the number six you thought I
forgot the fun fact for number six was
it was the first rule at number there's
been a lot of Roulette themes though
actually that I added to my repertoire
in ten years because I met Lizzy born on
the sixth added to the repertoire hasn't
done that well Lizzy you with a little
bit of me we're changing the QA world
whether they like it or not oh crap wait
subscribe to do I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so I know you forgot for
everybody that waited for the black
screen I appreciate the patience and
I'll see you soon subscribe
I want you to go like that and then I
want you to roll dark for a little bit
like like you know okay you're ready to
roll right